معظمنا يعرف جيدا فوائد ترفيهيه للسفر لكن
الجديد ان للسفر فوائد الصحيه ايضا دراسته
امريكيه حديثه اجراها الباحثون في جامعه
تكساس اظهرت ان اولئك الذين يسافرون
يبلغون او يبلغون عن نتائج صحيه افضل على
كل حال الاشخاص الذين لا يسافرون خارج
منطقههم يبلغون عن صحه اقل فقد تبين بحسب
الدراسه ان الاشخاص الذين لديهم فرص سفر
محدوده يعانون من ضعف في الصحه ووفقا
لدراسه يمكن ان يؤدي اجراء تفاعلات
اجتماعيه خلال السفر الى تحسين الحاله
المزاجيه والمساعده على الشعور بالسعاده
مما يقلل من خطر الاصابه بالخرف الامر لا
يقتصر على السفر الترفيهي الهجره ايضا لها
منافع صحيه فلدين يسافرون الى خارج
منطقتهم المحليه يتمكنون من الوصول لا
خيارات رعايه صحيه اكثر وربما افضل
يبدو ان فوائد السفر كثيره ومتنوعه نعدد
بعض هذه الفوائد لتعزيز صحتك النفسيه
المساعده على الشعور بالهدوء فالسفر ورؤيه
اماكن جديده يخفف من التوتر والضغط في
الحياه الاجتماعيه والمهنيه ويطيح للعقل
فرصه الاسترخاء والشفاء ويقلل من التعرض
للاكتئاب تحسين قوه العقل العقليه فتعلم
لغات جديده والذهاب الى اماكن جديده يفتح
العقل فالخروج من منطقه راحت الخاصه بك
يمكن ان يكون مفيدا لصحتك العقليه كما
يمكن ان يساعد الابتعاد عن العمل على
الشعور بمزيد من الانتاجيه والتركيز عند
العوده لان العقل يحتاج الى وقتين للراحه
زياده الابداع يمكن الاشخاص الذين يسافرون
اكثر ابتكار افكار متنوعه والتعرض لتقطات
جديده وتكوين صداقات دوليه وتعلم لغات
جديده وتناول انواع مختلفه من الطعام
والموسيقى ما يساعد على رؤيه العالم
بطريقه جديده دعم الحياه المهنيه
والعائليه فبعد السفر تشهر انك اكثر حيويه
ومستعد لتحمل كل ما ينتظرك في المنزل او
العمل تقدير قيمه المنزل فاختبار ثقافات
اخرى مختلفه من شانها ان يساعد على الشعور
بالتقدير اكثر لما يحيط بك عند عودتك الى
المنزل على كل حال سال ان الناس ما رايك
بالسفر خارج المواسم بعيدا عن الازدحام
وفي اوقات الدراسه والعمل نتابع
[موسيقى]
حقيقه يعني السفر شيء جميل
ولكن في وقت واحد يسافر بها ويرجع عشان
يغير جو حلو جدا اللي ما عندهم اطفال ما
عندهم التزامات لكن للناس اللي عندهم
ارتبطات زينه عندهم اطفال ما عندهم حل
لانهم مواسم والاسعار بتكون مره مره غاليه
بس هذا الحل يعني
[موسيقى]
متزوجات العائله يعني لازم يكون الاولاد
عندهم مدارس راح يكون موجود
[موسيقى]
يعني تخرجوا عيالك وقت المواسم والبعض لا
يفضل الدراسه ويانا والناس اللي يفضل يعني
السفر في همم بعد المواسم انه الزحام
الزحام والامور هذه اريح تقدر تاخذ راحتك
يعني تقدر تتمشى براحتك يعني وافضل يعني
[موسيقى]
من الجو حر نغم
صباح العربيه بماذا تنصحين كمدونه سفر كل
من يريد السفر بعيدا عن الترفيه ولكن همم
ابتعاده عن الضغط النفسي ضغط العمل وما
الى ذلك
يسعد صباحكم نادين وسهام خبروني اقول لكم
الاسبوع الجاي انكم مسافرين هيك على حساب
المجموعه شو رايكم
ممكن ممكن السفر
الاستثمار في السفر هو الاستثمار في نفسك
شو رايكم بهالمقوله
كثير في نفسكم او لا بس لو نرجع نركز في
المقوله شو قلتي نغم
الصوت
في السفر
من اول يوم بنخفض درجه 89
صدقيني حتى سكرات اللي مرتبطه بالعمل ممكن
اذا انت عرفت كيف تخطيطي لو تتعاملي مع
انك انت بعد ما تخلصي العمل تعرضي نفسك لا
تجارب وتطلعي وتروحي وجربي اشياء جديده
يعني مش معناها انك انت حتى اذا انت
سافرتي خلال العمل انت بتقابلي ناس جديده
تتعرفي على ثقافه جديده بتروحي على مطاعم
جديده
في العقل
اسرار طاقه ايجابيه اكثر او افكار ايجابيه
اكثر حتى كفرات العمل علميا ممكن ترفع
استخراج الدراسه اكثر
طيب نغم هناك من يسافر هناك ما ياخذون
اجازه مثلا عن العمل ويبقون في مناطقهم هل
انت مع الدراسه ان يسافر او ياخذ الحد
الاجازه خارج مناطق هو يتعرف على ثقافه
جديده وتفاعلات اجتماعيه جديده
داخل الدوله انت انتقم المكان الى ما
اختان اتعرف على تجارب جديده ثقافات جديده
خذ كلارس جديده عباره عن مثلا
هو العقل اللي بيحترمه انك انت بس شوفي
منظر جديد انت تعرض نفسك لا تجارب جديد او
مناظر
الناس مش بس انت عقلك بيتحول الى
اوتوماتيك بتعرف
نفس الشيء عقلك
طب نغم يعني ليه كل ما بعدنا اكثر كل ما
استفد اكتر
[موسيقى]
لانه كلمه انت بتشوفي اشياء جديده اكثر
حتى انت تنفتحي على نفسك
بيقولوا السفر يخلق عندك نوع من الابداع
ابداع جديد عشان هيك بتشوفي بيقول
الارجنتين بيقول قصرا النظر من عدم السفر
وتلاقي في كتابه كثيره
[موسيقى]
ههه
بس عنجد الصوت مش كثير واضح بالنسبه لنا
نتمنى بالمرات الجاي يكون اوضح عشان
نتفاعل معك اكثر شكرا نغم البدوي من
الدوحه خبيره ومدونه السفر شكرا